let's go next to our caller from I
believe this is country code 86 is that
correct is this country code 86 yes it
is is surge core job Oh - I do it what's
going on oh man look I'm not sure if you
remember but I'm in Wuhan China and I am
currently stuck in Wuhan China okay yeah
I'm sure you are you familiar with the
current outbreak of the corona virus yes
sir called an acute pneumonia okay well
yeah so I'm not sure if you're familiar
with the news that said that America was
or the American consulate were um
evacuating American citizens that were
in China I got a phone call I it is not
so much a question I'm just trying to
update people on the situation yes
ground here I'm sorry for hijacking your
situation I mean your show right now but
so hold on I gotta because they want to
understand this so you're living in in
China the US Embassy has started trying
to evacuate Americans you get a phone
call from the embassy and they say what
in Beijing and they said that I had a
seat on the chartered plane that was
leaving from one they were taking out
non-essential concert workers the
station here in one and including some
some citizens that work here most of us
ESL teachers and some of us worked for
private companies a few of my friends
actually made it on the plane
however I got the phone call the
gentleman told me a different time you
told me 7:00 a.m. it actually they told
I threw my friend's got an email saying
that he should be there at 7:00 p.m. it
was a whole kind of it was like a lot of
jumbled up information yeah so um me
person I didn't get a confirmation email
saying that my seat was confirmed so I
didn't want to waste anybody's resources
trying to get to the airfield because
the whole entire city is shut down the
public and private transportation is
limited public transportation shut down
completely I apologize and ride sharing
applications that shut down and they
cannot operate inside the city so yes
some people who pretty much they were
told that they could get a seat they
would turn away at the airport I'm also
in case people were wondering we will
have to reimburse Uncle Sam $1,100 for
the present one who California yeah yeah
yeah and some just so I'm ending all the
details let's let's slow down a little
bit so the flight the it was a charter
flight from Wuhan to California directly
well not direct I think they are they
stopped I think they would stop in
Ontario Canada and then fly into
California but the way the gentleman on
the phone was slated to me I think we
have an Ontario California no I know it
sounded like it was the brakes yeah okay
yeah so it was the direct flight to
California got it all right okay some
people believe that was that we they
would have a layover in California
candidate but a direct flight yes contra
and so so you missed the flight
essentially or you didn't end up getting
the details so now what happens or you
just have to stay there and wait it out
and hope you don't catch the the the
virus yeah pretty much from what I'm
from what I've been told is
person-to-person direct contact
everyone's wearing a face mask face mask
Minotaur in the city I rarely go out of
my apartment today I was a local
mini-mart got some water or some instant
noodles and more more food so I don't
have to leave in it and the next few
days but yeah pretty much
Wow Vinay I don't get it do you live in
like a big apartment building with a lot
of people yeah yeah it's a pretty
sizeable 18 floors and know who district
but people are just limiting their they
travel most people just hold up in their
homes I see you know the essential work
workers in the neighborhood taking care
of garbage and stuff like that however
yes very um today I barely saw the
chassis actually I did see some vehicles
on the road but for Rouen it was sparse
Wow Wow and and and have there been any
other instructions communicated like are
people being told just stay at home
pretty much yes that is the number one
instruction to stay in the house they
made contact with people outside your
home yeah monitor the conditions people
inside your home if you display any
flu-like symptoms please report yourself
to you know the the closest hospital
yeah so they may you know mining your
condition and so on and so forth Wow
all right well listen thank you for
checking in and giving us an update from
in there you know stay safe and and and
then give us a call next week and let's
see how things are going
will do thanks for letting me rent man I
appreciate it
all right Serge keep in touch good luck
there great to hear from you thank you